hey guys how's it going thanks for
joining me this morning I was getting
all philosophical about the same crap
that I usually do but I was thinking
about it more today because we are
rapidly approaching 9 million
subscribers on YouTube and that number
alone is extraordinary and the fact that
so many people follow me is more of the
motivation of why I want to use it for
good why I want to use this community
that we've built to make sure that we
make an impact on the world around us
and there's a lot of ways that I go
about this and there's a lot of reasons
why I got about this but the charity
livestreams are one thing one thing that
I want to do more of an I don't do
enough of mostly just because I don't
have the time to do it but there's more
components that I want to do and there's
more ways that I feel like we could do
good for the world as a whole and the
reasons behind that are numerous but in
case you guys didn't know my personal
philosophy is that I don't have a lot of
time on this world you know that doesn't
mean that I'm gonna die tomorrow but it
means that I could die tomorrow and it
does mean that you know eventually at
some point down the road I will die and
what I leave behind is all that will be
remembered of me and that sounds really
harsh and that sounds really you know
final and everything but that's my
philosophy on life and that's a big
motivator of what I do I know for a fact
that I will not last forever but what I
do and what I leave behind for those who
will follow me is the most important
thing that I could do in my life and
it's the most important thing that I
want to be in my life it's not just a
fact it's like what I take in for my own
personal use
it's how I shape my life and what I do
so when we're getting all these people
here in this community I don't want to
force my ideology on you but I would
like to try to guide you as a leader of
this community to try to adhere to
certain morals that I think are true now
this doesn't mean that you have to
accept it I'm not trying to brainwash
you about anything but as a whole I
believe that there's so much more than
weak
- as a community to better the world now
once again the charity livestreams are a
thing that is good and is great and is
definitely promoting goodwill out there
in the community but there's more that
we could do because everyone knows
there's a lot of suffering in the world
today there's a lot of things going
wrong there's a lot of people that are
oppressing other people and we as a
society together have a responsibility
to each and every person on this planet
neech and everything on this planet we
have an obligation to make sure that
this world is better than when we left
it we have an obligation to know that
the future generations that come after
us are going to live happier lives and
we did today more beneficial lives and
then they will carry on that knowledge
that we shape them to the next
generation and that's how society moves
forward and that's how society evolves
and grows into something that's bigger
and better than what we started with and
it all starts today and what we're doing
now and I'm not saying big grand
sweeping things just for your
entertainment I'm saying this just as a
simple fact you know it's a simple
statement of what I believe that we
should do because I mean so long as
there's any one person suffering in the
world that's that's our responsibility
that's our responsibility to make sure
that they live a better life because I
personally believe that if everyone gave
more than they took the world would be a
better place and again that's a bumper
sticker quote it's a bite-size piece of
everything that I believe and is two
bite-sized piece of the bigger problem
because there's so many other problems
you can't just will something to be
better it's slow progress and it's
encumbered by numerous failures like we
as people personally encounter so many
failures in our life and we encounter so
many obstacles that we need to overcome
personally how can we even think about
other people that need our help as well
but you know it's not a huge endeavor
it's not a huge thing that each and
every one of us needs to dedicate our
entire lives to do because we do have
our own personal lives to take care of
and we do have our personal circle of
people that we need to take care of our
family
our friends and outside of that things
grow dimmer and there's this quote that
I read recently that I don't know why I
hadn't read it before and I would
totally butcher it now I don't even
remember who said it in the first place
someone in the comments couldn't correct
me but it really liked it really was
really jarring to me because it really
made me think about how the world we
live in is the way that it is and it
goes something like every single person
has their own little bubble a few rings
that orbit around them and the closest
ring they have their friends in the
family their close ones who will always
be a part of them no matter what and
then outside of that you have the
friends that kind of drift in and out of
your life you know certain times over
the years they'll be introduced they'll
leave they'll break bonds they'll form
bonds people come in and out and then
outside of that ring there's everyone
else in the world and there's like a
blurred gray shadow moving across the
world in there they're living their own
lives and whether or not you reach out
to them will not affect their life
because you are in their third circle
and what was really mind-blowing about
it is the realization that you have this
entire network of people orbiting around
you and so does everyone else
every single person in this world has
that same network of people and is
living their own unique and vivid life
and they have their own struggles in
their own joys and their own things that
bring them joy and bring them pain and
bring them suffering and bring them
worry and it really was jarring to me
because I realized that if we all
expanded our circle a little bit we
would overlap just a few more people and
some people can take that negatively to
mean that we could affect their lives
negatively but I'd like to think the
reaching out to other people and trying
to help them would only be a positive
thing not only I mean I know certain
situations where it wouldn't be totally
good but in all honesty there is so much
more that could be done if every person
does a little bit more and anyway I'll
finish up this thought I I go on these
long trains of thoughts but the main
point that I'm trying to get across is
that there's so much more than we
as a huge network of almost 9 million
people now and I know for a fact that
there's something more and I haven't
nailed down the exact idea that I want
but I'm putting this out there to you
guys to try to try to kind of shape it
and form it because I go to a lot of
conventions and I meet a lot of people
and it's great I love that I love
meeting you guys and I love seeing the
impact that my videos have on you guys
but I can't help but feel that there's
something more that I could do on top of
that and I have this idea that I want
it's like I want to go back to
Cincinnati not not just to visit my
friends and family but I want to go back
to Cincinnati
I'm having a moment here I want to go
back to Cincinnati because I want to
have a meet-up but I don't just want to
have a meet-up where everyone comes and
sees me and is like oh yay markiplier I
don't want just that to be the reason
why I gather everyone in one place
because I feel like if everyone's going
to be gathered in one place there should
be a really good reason for it and the
idea that I have that's not fully formed
is I want to have a volunteering meetup
a day or a weekend where we get together
in one place
say Cincinnati for example and we just
go out into the city and we volunteer
everywhere we can everywhere that needs
a place for people to volunteer I've
like teams that people could go and buy
cans of food to donate to food banks
people could go get clothes and donate
to them people could go out and gather
people could clean up the streets people
could clean up parks like together if we
get like even a thousand people in one
place which is an extraordinary amount
of people I've seen several thousand
people in one place and it's an
extraordinary amount of people but I
feel like that would be so much better
than just having a meet-up it would be a
meet-up that could literally change the
face of an entire city in a weekend and
like of course Cincinnati is a big city
but we could like like another idea is
like if we had if I was to do a tour
across the country I wouldn't want it to
just be a tour where I go up on stage
and like look
me looking look out how me I am look
look at the me that I is like we could
have a tour where we could go city to
city and we could do the same thing we
could volunteer at every city we could
go to him we could go to across the
country in each city big or small and we
could like change the face of that city
a day at a time just have people and
then even cities that I'm not in other
cities around the country could like use
that as an excuse to go out and help the
community that they're in because I want
you know there's something about charity
livestream there's something about what
it does and it does a lot of good but
there's something else about the
inspirational quality of tangible
seeable like observable change that's
going on in the community and like just
going out and trying to help people on
an individual level but on an enormous
scale is something that really appeals
to me and again this is just an idea I
have not formulated any of this I just
like thought this up this morning is
something that I really wanted but I'm
putting it out there like in the
universe because if there's someone or
if there's a company or there's a
charity organization or a non-profit
society that does this sort of thing or
can help organize this sort of thing
that's what I want to know I really want
to know how to make this idea come true
because like like I've said before ideas
are at the heart of everything that we
as humans do ideas are the things that
shape who we are and ideas are what
shape our society into becoming better
and becoming you know growing as you
know instead of being so self-centered
Society we are a more open society
that's open to helping other people and
open to growing as a people and and
these ideas that I have you know some of
them may falter and and some of them may
not work like but I feel that there's
something really here to the point where
we have so many people in this community
and we have such a world that we live in
where this network of people can grow
exponentially both on the internet and
on the streets like we have this thing
where we can grow the circle of every
person and everyone else that is
involved in their lives and if more
people are reaching out to other people
for support and more people give
then they take then the world can be a
better place so anyway that way that's
enough rambling for me but these these
are the things that I want and I
definitely want to do more of these
vlogs with you guys it's not like I said
it's not a sake of laziness it's a sake
of time because I am one person and I
can only do so much good as one person
but as the person who you all look up to
I have an extreme responsibility to
guide you in the right direction so take
this idea for what it is let me know in
the comments I'm going to be reading the
comments extensively here let me know
what you think of the idea and how more
importantly how this idea can be made a
reality because if we don't act on our
ideas and we don't act on the feel-good
inspirations then there was no point
saying it in the first place
I don't want to just be a wordsmith up
here that says pretty things even though
I can say stupid things all the time
but I don't want to just be a figurehead
that is quotable I want to actually be
on the ground and I want to actually do
something and I want to actually change
the world because that's what's really
important that's always what's going to
be really important so either way thank
you all so much for watching thanks for
listening to my ramblings take this idea
please let me know what you think of it
and how it can be made into something
big so thank you again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye bye bye bye